are you both doing today good yeah I'm
doing good
I have so this had to have been what I
call a fun shoot or am I wrong about
this it was a fun shoot it was so fun
probably the most fun I've had him in my
life on a job thus far I hit so much I
think because I came out with so much
all I got to conquer certain things I've
done before but I came in with great
friends like he can't ask for more than
that how much did you guys know so you
have a meeting about the show how much
are you told about the entire arc and
how much is it sort of like here's a
broad stroke and we're gonna hand you a
bunch of scripts we were told quite a
bit I mean you know things are always
subject to change if they're not written
but I was told almost everything yeah
same here
most old everything which is why I was
so crazy about it and I was kind of in
awe by the time might finish telling me
the whole story of this entire journey
but it was kind of cool is I he set
everything and then he only we only had
like episode 1 we didn't get everything
at once so you have to work our way on
our way
earn our keep the whole time I'm just
thinking about what the okay so you go
into the meeting had you been offered
the role or were you sort of you know
what I mean I talk a little bit about
that in assess and how nervous are you
going into a meeting like that with like
the creator of the show are you like
please I got to make sure I don't say
the wrong thing yeah yeah that's like
the first fear in every meeting yeah I
hope my work more the right outfit I
don't have like please God I don't let
me be anything
I was not offered the part it was a
meeting where you know it's like I guess
essentially you're both interviewing
each other
sure and mike is really charming
interesting smart person to meet and I
just love talking to him so much and I
trusted him in the meeting and some of
the things he told me that happened in
the series or that would eventually
happen were like I I had a large
reaction to
some tears gripping my heart you won't
be dissatisfied at the end of this
series there are a lot of things in the
store that I don't think people will
expect mm-hmm yeah oh well for me yeah I
mean the first thing is like please
don't let me sound like an idiot
let's get out of this sounding like an
intelligent human being but I had a face
I was out of town so I didn't get to
meet with him face to face so they I
read the script they asked me what I
thought and they're like if you like it
they want to talk to you so I was like
no I love it
I'd love to hear what this is going
let's let's get a FaceTime going I think
the hardest thing about a FaceTime call
is that I have such a crappy phone that
it just kept blacking out I'm like Mike
Kenny here I'm gonna call you back okay
it just went dark so like we go after we
go through all that crap he told me the
whole I got a better phone one upgraded
after that I was like screw this but
then yeah I was just so amazed I wasn't
offered the part either it's like kind
of like a you know an interview back and
forth you're kind of figuring it out but
after we both clicked you know it kind
of just came my way and I was so excited
I could be mistaken but I don't think
Netflix has a show like this I think
this is like their first like type of
show in this vein or am I wrong about
this I don't think there's really
anything like this out right now this
like 90s esque thriller which is what
was so exciting about it - yeah I do
think that it's original at the moment
completely the thing I took away I've
seen the first few episodes is that it's
constantly pulling back you know layers
of the onion if you will there's always
stuff to kind of so is that every
episode yes I mean I cannot believe my
can create that in his brain like it
would I don't understand but yes they
will be peeling off until the very last
minute of the show yeah no I'm just
trying to wonder where it's all gonna go
you have no
and we're not talking for both both of
you what's like a day or two you're
always gonna remember from filming
either be from like a mess up who
screwed up bad take whatever it may be
one day I will always remember is
marrying James I think that was our
first day we'd also we'd already met and
had a nice dinner and gotten to know
each other a little bit but the fact
that was like a big that was a big day
and there were so many extras there that
we did not know who they were we had to
get these like heartfelt speeches and
you had Mike and our director Philip
behind the camera on there you're just
feeling the pressure of nailing that's
the first day but that was just so
beautiful to me I mean it looked
beautiful
there's we just felt comfortable it kind
of felt like these people were our
friends like it was that'll be something
I'd remember forever there are so many
days that I'm like which one - I'm like
trying to think of one that's like at
least happy my character has so many
terrible things happened to her that
there was like a lot of many hours I
mean I guess I remember screaming crying
yeah yeah what did you like doing like
the meetings the biotech meetings oh god
those were really hard - they didn't
remember well the Backstreet Boys they
needed to pull the Marlon Brando
earpiece yeah there were some days I
mean I had a lot of like medical jargon
which is kind of the hardest thing to
memorize because it's not like
emotionally connected to anything and I
work on that yeah but Jane had the
hardest job I think with everything
she's got going on she does an
incredible job and everyone's gonna love
it
thanks guys excited a few Funk westerns
before around the time what besides this
show obviously uh what TV show would you
love to guest star on I just finished
watching Umbrella Academy and I think
it's like a lot you know it's like a
superhero show but it's got that Royal
Tenenbaums kind of kind of feel to it
I'd love to to go on that
got to start filming a second season
yeah please catch me I'm unemployed I'll
be great I would like to guest star on
my best friend Mays TV show good girls
on NBC I think you may be able to make
that happen
I'm gonna be like that does feel like
you could maybe do you remember your
first movie or TV show crush yeah yeah
that was very fast and I don't remember
his name but he was in the little giants
the little blonde Oh
devon Sawa yeah I remember but I
remember like this is probably like
narcissism but I guess I was a kid so
you're allowed to be a narcissist but I
was like I'm gonna marry him y'all don't
know I uh yeah I guess I had to I know I
know my first sounds ridiculous cartoon
I was in love with bubbles from the
Powerpuff Girls the worst everybody
hears laughing right the worst part it
was also also Topanga from Boy Meets
World levels was the phrase just like I
feel like she we would get along so well
I would think when I was a kid that
there was a way that I kind of like the
pagemaster like where you could just get
sucked in like I was just waiting for
that day to meet bubbles but it never
happened the worst part is this is two
years ago it's very recent them just
doesn't call me back and I'm still I'm
still figuring myself out listen
Congrats on the show I can't wait to
finish it and thank you so much for your
time thank you